mi ricordavo l'ultima volta mi sono
incazzato così tanto per un videogame
comunque ragazzi
no perché la musica è bella e
orecchiabile però so già che il gioco mi
farà bestemmiare
tanti ragazzi e prevede che sono video
sono fa vigente ma ci sono su core
symphony 2 che a vederlo così ragazzi
non sembra assolutamente male il
problema è che non abbiamo ancora
iniziato un uomo torna nel suo mondo per
riprendersi ciò che ha perduto senza
sapere che da quando se ne andò a tutto
è cambiato quindi io sono questo uomo
straniero a casa propria capitolo
azzurro allora funziona così io
praticamente cambio scenario e le cose
scompaiono fantasmini è un macello vuoi
tradito dai miei amici ed esiliato dal
mondo degli umani raccoglie tutti i
cappelli che trovi nel diventa scusa
frate vento ragazzi se si cambia
scenario appaiono delle cose non sembra
troppo difficile credo è scherzavo via
passato fu cancellato è la mia realtà
micetto nella cupa disperazione ragazzi
c'è della narrazione in sa cosa
fantastico ci sono voluti molti anni per
che riprendesse coscienza di me stesso
sentito parla di meno e gioca di più
però questo non è più il posto che
conosce che ha ho capito fermi lì ho
capito sono solo stupido viene più il
posto che conosce bene credo se se
vivere in un posto dove la roba scompare
c'è sticazzi ok mi caricava ogni tanto
faccio se stai mosse da eh vabbè ragazza
è arrivata una rotta che separa lo
sharing e na roba indecente è
impossibile ma porca eva affermi nativo
allora è saltato un tasto e saltato un
altro tasto fotte sega ce la posso fare
hano piano fiamma in quel modo tutto
secco e senza vita tua norme che certo
c'è chi spegne come faccio a non è così
non si può
porca la fontana alla tra [ __ ]
[ __ ] tutti al o succhia il gelato e
quello alla pesca perfetto siamo al
terzo livello ragazzi e la mia tastiera
e così meraviglioso piano non so ok
adesso sono tutto ciò che conoscevo e
scomparso zio e guarda ci sono dei
cappelli il problema è questo questo è
successo qua non lo so però se un
ragazzo incazzato molto incazzato è
questa cosa te la posso assicurare frate
2 vado ok ok di qua è fin qua eh vabbè
ogni tanto me ne so queste pro agili e
anche queste stronzate ma se ci pensate
ragazze è abbastanza geniale il concept
di gioco sono quello vero perché il
resto fa bestemmiare vero zio no
[Musica]
ragazzi fatemi capire un attimo se posso
finire livello si possa ho fatto tutto
ciò che posso fare andare avanti
confidando nei miei ricordi lo zio devi
confidare in tua madre
credimi è molto più semplice cosa ho
fatto mio dio porca vacca perché ho
cambiato scenario sono in collina non è
mi deve arrivare la pizza ragazzi voglio
finire sto gioco prima che mi arrivi la
pizza si è fatto a fare dai tyka il suo
perfetto no dai dai dai dai su perfetto
vaffan formato a malta il proprio
pesante porca eva che gioco di merda
proprio non mi può spiegare
no non me lo voglio sapere niente
beh sì no sì no no no no
no ho già detto no vedete che il menù
era beh il menù del gioco era tranquillo
solo quello però cazzo porca [ __ ]
ladra era difficile sono quinto in tutto
il mondo grazie grazie
nel rifugio sicuro dei miei vecchi
compagni di squadra ho trovato una
registrazione che racconta cosa è
successo finora
a me che cazzo me ne frega a me basta
che finisco il gioco zio non è che me ne
frega tanto 6 simone vanni archi team
mazzarella madre co star o la posso
attivarne 2 fantastico ho capito ad
action messo una vita a capirlo ma l'ho
capito fantastico per justin bieber ma
[ __ ]
si ok cazzano nostro ritornato di non
uccidono ma non abbiamo potuto ma quali
john levi fumate prima di fare sti
giochi fatemi capire con mio zio che
trip nota porca lights e in cosa sto
dicendo madonna che bordello è questo
non c è la leva lercia la eva eva lercia
e valeva anche adamo anche adamo porco a
danno dei io non ci posso fare davanti
agli artigiani non ce la posso fare
regali non ci riescono proprio a volte
minissale il gesù in una maniera che
provo anche gesù risale gesù così
proprio da tanto gesù tanto diciamo no
al colesterolo e si la tua madre ok o
minchia non ci posso credere che cazzo
[Musica]
e dopo questa messi e direi che posso
passare oltre ragazzi sta diventando
osceno cioè ve lo dico è un bordello
nello dovadola non dovendo va ad osh iq
che cazzo sto facendo aiuto perfetto non
so cosa ragazzi sto facendo
completamente a caso ma caso in una
maniera incredibile a posare questo
andare anche di sopra di te lo aveva la
faccia per il giallo quello blu
oddio oddio oddio piano piano che mi sta
aprendo infarto ma sappia quando mi
prende bene che riesco a fare
calmati stai calmo stai calmo stai calmo
non è stata la scelta migliore ma è
tutto ciò che potevamo fare io non ci
voglio giuro che non ci sto veramente
sto sforzandomi di crederci perchè giuro
mi sta salendo lo sgarbi ok
fantastico il leader è pazzo e vabbè ho
capito mi fai attaccare a qualcosa a
parte al cazzo da ragazzi sapete che tra
questo e super meat boy non so quale più
difficile sci azzurro veramente questa è
una roba pazzesca
se se sei cazzo si per grazia di dio
madonna
madonna sto per avere un infarto
registro queste parole perché non riesco
ad accettare questo destino neanch'io
zio non ci posso più fare [ __ ]
[ __ ] de casino
ok questo mondo cosa l'ho cambiato non
abbiamo ancora trovato la risposta
all'osso io chi è stato è stato gesù
stato colui che ha detto ma perché non
facciamo un gioco brutto per farvi j
e allora abbiamo cambiato città sta
merda semplice vero
porca vacca ladra dio dio dio dio ci
sono ragazzi ci saranno so come non so
come giallo giallo giallo ok limite
arriva la findim incarico alla fine non
so ok non voglio sapere che ho fatto che
tutto ciò che sappiamo nel mondo
vinciate a cambiare dopo che leader ha
fatto qualcosa che cazzo ha fatto suo
leader lo prendiamo a schiaffi sto
leader non lo sapremo mai ragazze tutte
iniziato a morire tra suonando questo
mondo in una landa desolata allora il
bello di sto gioco
il bello è che ha una storia pian piano
che passi livelli la seguì solo più sono
talmente incazzato che non la sto
seguente non si capì non posso
ok manca la parte finale che non farò
mai ma è stato bello ciao mamma ti ho
voluto bene
lo sapevo però c'ero quasi cazzo va bene
che ho capito questo livello non lo farò
mai quindi ci vediamo direttamente al
prossimo episodio rega proprio così ok
mamma mi dicono che un quoziente
intellettivo discretamente alto non ci
voglio credere non lo bue o crea dai
paesi allora
non c'è verso che finisco livello mid
olimpica giuro cazzo cazzo
ragazzi io mi sento di concludere qui
l'episodio perché vi giuro che
potrebbero diventare molti ma molti di
più questi tasti in giro la prima volta
che mi incazzo così tanto in sé non mi
ricordavo l'ultimo temi sono incazzato
così tanto in un gioco mi pare che fosse
che mario credo che è che mario fosse
l'ultimo gioco da primi fatti incazzare
così tanto ma non mi ricordavo in
videogame così ve lo giuro è assurdo non
mi ricordavo l'ultima volta mi sono
incazzato così tanto per un mito che
comunque ragazzi io con quello che
l'episodio spero che mi sia piaciuto a
me è piaciuto molto nel senso che a me
piace giocare a queste cose insomma da
tre si è salvato solo tasto f5
stranissimo prima o poi avrei dovuto
giocare qualcosa che mi ha fatto mifare
mia premier non può più parlare
l'italiano gesù ramo caduto il
telecomando quindi concluso episodio non
aprirò mai più questa merda ma non ci
tengo mai nella vita e va bene così e
noi ci vediamo fosse bisogno lasciamo
perdere facciamo finta e aver giocato un
cazzo
domani gioco hello kitty serio
bene da ragazzi